hi I'm Chris Evans and I'm Mark Ruffalo
and we're gonna take a BuzzFeed quiz to
find out whether or not we would have
survived the else's snap can you read a
little slowly I'll do my best
[Music]
would you most like to get your hands on
one of them technically but what would I
want to get my hands on to reality
options are reality power mind time soul
in space I mean I'm going mind I'm going
time which Disney character would you
choose to join Avengers I love Queen
Elsa Hercules gee sorcerer Mickey
Elastigirl or stitch I mean there's
there's function and then there's just
personal I'm gonna go from a standpoint
of function it's got to be Genie I'm
gonna cheat you know you're kind of any
which world would your word which word
your friend used to describe you caring
kit oil yep creative funny kind
successful I'm kind of your friend I'm
gonna say my you're kind and successful
I think my buddies would say loyal
that's that's what I my buddy oh sure
they wouldn't say one that's typical
mark which is your favorite MCU dynamic
do whoa hope and Scott Thor Loki Steven
Bucky the size Bros Gamora and they're
gonna carry your buddy you good and
young which one which one you gonna go
for you can't believe in yourself right
that's a real that would be lame right
Carolyn I'm gonna go with the science
Bros and you are not just cuz you're
here just be kind of going with Steve
and Bucky had a boy that's not why I did
it
which weird or a superpower would you
want as s alright the power to
instantaneously learn any language by
only hearing it once the power to change
the nutritional value of any food to
your will that's mine the facts either
the power to remember
anything you need and recall it
instantly the power to make any and all
clothing items fit you perfectly as if
Taylor keep it that you're an [ __ ]
the power to transform into any animal
you can think of real or imaginary
you're making this tough buzz be the
power to always know with absolute
certainty when someone is why you need
that your view you have to reassess your
life I'm gonna have to have the power to
know with absolute certainty when
someone is lying though that flies in
the face of what I just mumbled under my
breath okay the only thing is making me
the second guys I the power to transform
into any animal fly the all number one
thing is to remember anything you read
and recall it instantly how can you not
you still got to deal with the idiots I
think I'm gonna go with the animals I
remember the title of grounded and what
this is about its surviving the snap oh
wait a minute I'm just doing this for me
all right I'm still gonna take the
animal okay okay whose origin story is
your personal favorite I mean well how
does that have to do with the snap Tony
Stark Steve Rogers or Stephen strange to
chawla or Carol Danvers where's origin
story I'm gonna go away that is mine
wait there's no any start I'm gonna go
with the yeah those dyed eyebrows I'm
gonna go with Steve Rogers I mean look
at that
boy tell you what I love that it was you
were on there I would vote for you thank
you I'm gonna go with 20 stock and
finally Obama finally I'm enjoy the best
what would you say is your personal
character flaw where's none now wait
what is this him to do with this morning
find out I joke around too much I have a
short temper I get hurt you deeply I'm
too damn cool
I couch army I can be a little too blunt
I'm always confident I'm not always not
is a big piece of that oh I'm sorry
I could be a little bit reckless I would
say you probably care too deeply I was
gonna say that but that's like the most
like it's okay you care too deeply
deeply oh well that's better than these
times and the next one was I'm not I was
confident but cool I'm not too blunt
yeah a little if she had a no temper the
reckless thing may be the thing I've
been in the car with you late at night
you sure have maybe I can be a little uh
oh you're not feeling so good no I'm
sorry to want to tell you this but you
did not survive the pain oh snap I don't
know what to do about this
that sucks man this is bull man
I'm gonna tweet this out
[Music]